on the outskirts of Bogota there's a
ravine through which clean water flows
free of trash where nature can develop
freely nothing special oh yes it is when
you know how it used to look Sophia
Lopez grew up here as soon as poss on do
stink on track it was a rubbish dump car
tires were lying around leftover food
anything no one wanted garbage plastic
even dead bodies plasticos a
desafortunadamente esta Muertos until
recently busca Calderon Tejada wasn't
much different from other
underprivileged Barrios or neighborhoods
in Bogota there were no jobs few
prospects instead drugs and gangs
Conservation International wanted to
change that sociologist Octavio
Rodriguez is a member of the
organization these of he Lopez and many
other people worked hard to make the
ravine look the way it does now 53 cubic
meters of rubbish had to be removed at
8,500 trees were planted donated by the
Botanical Garden but it all would have
been pointless if the people who live
here had been neglected take these men
for example many of them are former
criminals Edwin de pasco para served six
years in prison for drug trafficking now
he and others from the neighborhood are
maintaining the ravine in his present
state and he earns a little money doing
so the project began in 2011 and seems
to be having a positive effect on the
local crime rate
the SMS email for a month and a half not
one crime has been registered here any
will naturally licked you the people
monitor themselves they love their
berrio again and now they want to have
control over it and over the ravine
that's very important then people are
reclaiming their lives and their
environment that's also important
because the conservationists will soon
be withdrawing completely from the
project what happens then your project
is designed to perpetuate itself the
people have to carry it on themselves
it's easy Edwin tabasco para already has
a plan for a business for the time after
the project ends and stops paying him he
wants to organize a trash disposal
service so he can support his family